JUDITH D. SINGER: Good
afternoon, everybody.
I'm Judy Singer.
I'm the Senior Vice Provost
for Faculty Development
and Diversity and I want
to welcome all of you
on behalf of the
Office of the Provost
to this event on stylish
academic writing.
I was describing to a
colleague over the weekend
this particular event.
And he said, isn't
that an oxymoron?
And unfortunately, having
to read a lot of prose
across a lot of
disciplines, sometimes it
does sound like
it is an oxymoron.
But I think today what
we're going to learn
is that it is possible to write
well, write clearly, and write
for your colleagues.
I approach thinking
about this event
from several different
perspectives.
One is, I remember my first
year of graduate school,
turning in a paper
to my advisor.
My PhD is in statistics.
My advisor was Fred Mosteller.
He was known as a
very good writer.
And I turned in
my paper and I got
it back and there
was so much red ink
on it I was just traumatized.
From the first sentence,
he just circles.
My sentence began, there are.
I thought that was a perfectly
fine way to begin a paper.
Never begin a paper with
the words there are I
have never written a paper
or a paragraph with the words
there are since.
In fact, I basically avoid it.
And then over the
years, I see this
from in multiple perspectives
of thinking about the problem
space, one are the
arguments, sometimes heated,
that I get into
with my colleagues,
both about our own writing
and in collaborative work,
but also with our
graduate students,
arguments about the active
voice versus the passive voice.
The number of papers I
read where it's not clear
that any human being was ever
involved in the research,
because it either comes from
God or is done by monkeys.
But there is certainly
no human in the prose.
Coming up with
students who say to me,
but my other reader said I had
to edit all these words out.
And I'm, no, you have
to put them back in.
So it's obviously
an area in which
we can hold different views
about what is considered
stylish academic writing.
I also have a
particular perspective
of being involved in most of
the appointments processes
across the university,
and therefore
reading appointments
dossiers and tenure
dossiers across
the universities,
as well as papers from
a variety of fields.
And what goes for stylish
writing in one field
is very different from what
happens in another field.
I also make a parenthetical
note that my favorite dossiers
are written by Steve Pinker.
You should be lucky
enough to have Steve
make your case for tenure.
It's really quite a statement.
The idea for this event came
when Helen Sword contacted me,
said she was going
to be in the States
and was interested in speaking
with a group of faculty
about this topic.
And we have been
running a series
on publishing more
generally for the faculty
from a variety of perspectives.
And the notion of thinking
about how to write well
was something that was
quite appealing to us.
But we had to figure out how to
time this with Helen's schedule
since she comes from the
other side of the planet.
And then we wanted to have
two other perspectives
on the panel, one
of a faculty member
who thinks quite closely
about writing and every word
and how it's presented,
and Steve Pinker
was very gracious in accepting
our invitation, as well
as Elizabeth Knoll from
Harvard University Press, who
has done a lot of work with
us on these book publishing
events.
And if you're interested
in learning about the book
publishing business,
I can think of no one
better than Elizabeth
Knoll to be your guide.
So with those
opening remarks, I'm
going to turn this over
to Amy Brand, my colleague
in the Provost's office,
Assistant Provost
for Faculty Appointments
and Faculty Appointments,
who by the way, was an editor at
MIT Press in a former lifetime,
so really comes out of the book
publishing industry as well.
And thank you very
much for coming.
Bye, bye.
AMY BRAND: Good
afternoon and welcome.
We're delighted to see faculty
from across the university
at this event.
And we're going to
start the panel out
with our invited
guest, Helen Sword.
Helen is the author of the book
that you now have in your hands
I hope, the namesake
for the panel,
Stylish Academic Writing.
Helen is originally from
Southern California.
She received her PhD in
comparative literature
from Princeton and now teaches
at the University of Auckland
as Professor and
Director for the Center
of Learning and Research
in Higher Education.
Helen is an outspoken
advocate for creativity
and craftsmanship in
scholarship and has
offered workshops on
popular academic writing
all over the world.
In fact, we are just the second
stop on a 14 university tour
that she's in the
middle of right now.
Helen will be followed by
Elizabeth, Executive Editor
at Large at Harvard
University Press.
And as Judy
mentioned our offices
go to person on all matters
related to book publishing.
Elizabeth holds a PhD in
the history of science
and has been doing book
acquisitions since 1988.
As the range of fields that
she acquires and continues
to expand, she in her
own words, consequently
knows less and less
about more and more.
I take issue with
that, actually.
Elizabeth knows
a lot about a lot
and will offer an editor's
perspective on Helen's remarks.
And batting clean up
we have Steve Pinker.
Steve is Harvard College
Professor and Johnstone Family
Professor in the Department
of Psychology and author
of many blockbuster titles for
the general reader on language
evolution, the mind, and
most recently on violence,
with Better Angels
of Our Nature.
Steve has received so many
awards and recognitions
that I won't attempt
to list them,
but most recently he was named
one of Prospect Magazine's
top 10 World Thinkers for 2013.
So our plan for the
panelists comments to last,
hopefully no more than an
hour, leaving plenty of time
for your questions
and discussion.
So Helen, start with you.